oh thank you so much it is great to be
back here and even better to see so many
familiar faces we had an amazing
experience on xbox 360 doing oblivion
fallout 3 Skyrim and we're excited to
finally bring what's special about our
games to xbox one we like to build the
biggest craziest game worlds we can and
when that world is fallout there's
nothing else is fun to build in fallout
4 you experience the events of a nuclear
war forced to abandon your home you take
shelter in an underground vault events
transpire and you emerge 200 years later
the sole survivor a vault 111 this is an
enormous dynamic world where you can
create any kind of character you want go
wherever you want and do whatever you
want player freedom is our number one
goal
this is my character Phil here on your
pip-boy you can see all of my
appropriate stats my items and such and
we really want to make this come to life
so much so we've even built a second
screen experience that mimics the
pip-boy on your smartphone it works
amazing this is running on a next
generation version of our creation
engine features full physical based
rendering as well as dynamic volumetric
lighting
and then you returned home to find the
family robot still waiting it's ready
you God's worth your you're still here
so other people could still be alive too
it's worse than I thought you're
suffering from hunger induced paranoia
perhaps I can win you up a snack what
food yeah sure I I need a minute to
think then I'll be right back after
returning to your neighborhood you then
start exploring this world there are
many people you can meet as well as
faithful companions boy you doing here
all by yourself you want to come with me
pal okay then let's stick together it
does feature first-person combat as well
as our bat system
Oh
hey you you see that laser musket on the
ground grab it and head inside you've
got a group trapped in here this laser
musket is one of our signature weapons
in the game you crank it and then let it
loose
man I don't know who you are but your
time is impeccable Preston Garvey as you
can see we're in a bit of a mess here a
month ago there were 20 of us yesterday
there were eight now we're 5 i'll help
if I can well we do have one idea
from here you'll explore the most
ambitious game world that we have ever
created
welcome home